now while he was in the u.s. doom was
basically leading a dual life on one
hand he went to State University which
was the standard university that most
superheroes went to in Mobile Comics of
course you know Spiderman went there in
his and it's basically a New York State
University you know NYU New York
University or you know something along
those lines but it's basically a
university in New York City itself the
dual life that he lived came in the form
of the fact that he was a college
student to the eyes of the world around
him but beyond that he was also working
on the application of technology for
military uses and this was derived from
the fact that he basically used
technology to cast out the Baron and to
kill almost all of his soldiers the
problem with this is that once Doom is
in State University he encounters Reed
Richards for the very first time now
this is a big deal because over the
course of his life when he had been
casting out the band when he had been
fighting soldiers when he had been
increasing his own intelligence by
virtue of magic and so on and so forth
doom was virtually unrivaled there was
no one in the village that could propose
a challenge to him when it came to his
intellect but wheezes State University
Reed Richards is just as smart and in
some instances he's actually smarter now
this is kind of the give-and-take in
Marvel Comics with Reed Richards and dr.
doom we run into scenarios where doom is
smarter than Reed were read as smarter
than doom it really just depends on the
circumstance but it's largely accepted
that both Reed and doom are considered
to be individuals who trade the number
one spot for the smartest people in the
Marvel Universe but the fact remains
here that for doom his ambience you know
his his atmosphere his belief system was
that he had no interest in your
traditional American pursuits not only
that he would routinely contradict
professors he was out he wasn't really
incorrigible so much as he saw himself
as kind of better than those around him
and so the result is that he didn't
really inspire ill-will towards people
it was really more of women finding him
curious and those individuals who were
not Reed Richards basically being
fascinated by his intelligence and
wanting to pursue a role in in dooms
life in terms of helping him with his
experiments but in the end the issue
here was at doom was always in some
former fashion a social outcast and this
is just a continuation of his life from
being in that Romani village even when
he was running the show even when he was
sort of leading the Romani millage he
was still a social outcast people didn't
look at
as one of their own they looked at him
as sort of an outsider who may could
benefit from and so while he tries to
partake in party life while he tries to
partake in romance the issue here is
that when a woman hits on doom when she
initially makes you know advances
towards him he turns her down not only
that he seems to have a psychotic break
in the sense that he starts choking this
woman having flashbacks to the soldier
that originally tried to kill him and so
of course this does nothing to bolster
his reputation this does nothing to to
make him better not only that the
experiments that he starts getting
involved in start becoming more extreme
but something else that I hope you
noticed is that doom is beginning the
process of developing doombots now for
those of you guys who don't know doom
bots are basically stand-ins for Victor
Von Doom under normal circumstances doom
will rarely actually leave Latveria he
usually stays in Liberia almost 100% of
the time the doom bots are the ones that
go out and they usually carry out his
campaigns now sometimes the doom bots
takes the place of him in a battle the
doom bots will fight for dr. doom though
you know the doom bots will fight in his
stead other times the doom bots will be
you know ambassadors they will simply do
whatever it is an ambassadors do on
behalf of dr. doom but rarely does he
actually leave you know the the nation
of Liberia itself the other half of this
is that the doom bots are for all
intents and purposes Doctor Doom they
have the same memories they have the
same abilities the armor is composed of
the same composition an individual who
walked up and talked to a Doombot would
not know the difference between that
doom bots and the actual Doctor Doom
that's how well their design now these
are just primitive models these are just
primitive primitive forms so nowhere
near as advanced as they would become
but they're created for military
applications so they're designed to be
used by the military but for whatever
the military would choose to use them
for the issue here is that over the
course of his time because Reed Richards
is so intelligent and because Reed
Richards is kind of curious you know
about Doctor Doom
he eventually stumbles into his room and
starts rummaging through some of his
artifacts and when Victor walks in and
finds Reed doing this we learn a little
bit more about the ultimate goal of dr.
doom when Doom showed up in the United
States when he came there for the
purpose of learning it was basically to
find a way to retrieve his mother's soul
that if he sold his mother Sultan
devil then likely she's being held or or
something to basically either
communicate with her or bring her back
now
doom does not realize the full extent of
his mother's capture he doesn't realize
a full extent of what happened to her
when she died but he actually find out
here in a second what happens is that
once doom reveals or once once Reid
learns everything that's going on with
dooms life about the death of his mother
about the death of his father so on and
so forth there's a bit of remorse here
you know Reid feels bad for him slightly
and so the two of them begin engaging in
an experiment of sorts and doom is
basically sent or at least his mind is
sent to the realm of Mephisto now
Mephisto is kind of like the Marvel
analog for Satan but not directly there
Marvel Comics there isn't really like a
heaven and a hell per se and this sense
of their is unlike DC with
judeo-christianity in Marvel there's
just a lot of analogues for Heaven and
Hell for example in north mythology in
the realm of Thor and Asgard there's an
actual hell but that's the place for as
Guardians you know for those individuals
who believe in the Asgardian belief
system and they end up dying you know of
you know for whatever reason or they die
of noble acts you know they may go to
hell or they may go someplace else but
in the realm of Mephisto he exists as a
demon that basically tricks people his
goal is to capture human souls or
capture souls of any sentient being and
to hold those souls in his own Dominion
now within his own realm
Mephisto is at his strongest when he
leads his own realm he gets weaker the
longer he's away and so what happens is
with dr. doom showing up in the realm of
Mephisto he learns that his mother that
her soul is being held by Mephisto that
that was the price that the price of her
actions was being granted the power to
cast off the soldiers as best she could
but also the death of the firstborn
children the death of the children in
the village but also the soul of her
mother now this is extremely important
and the reason why is because while the
origin story will continue on and touch
on this you know in some different ways
what this tells us or at least what Ed
Brubaker is telling us is that from this
point going forward the actions of dr.
doom Center are on trying to free his
mother's soul his entire purpose in
Marvel Comics no matter what he does his
quest for absolute power his desire to
capture you know the heart of the
universe or the power of the Beyonder or
the Infinity stone whatever it may be
all of that centers around his goal a
free his mother's soul from a fist oh
and the reason for this is Mephisto is
extremely powerful in the realm of
Marvel Comics he's basically a cosmic
entity so he has the same power you know
as the Celestials you know and Galactus
and so on and so forth um it waxes and
wanes depending on the circumstances but
if we take Mephisto at his peak he's
just as powerful as anybody else
save for eternity or infinity and he's
certainly not as powerful as the Living
Tribunal or the one above all but he's
still a very capable being now is
something else to also note here though
is that he's not on the same level as
Franklin Richards there have been
stories where Mephisto reveals that he's
terrified of the power the Franklin
Ventures has and Franklin has actually
gone to the realm of Mephisto and beat
him in his own realm so that is not an
impossible situation that's not an
impossible scenario the issue here is
that in the end
Mephisto cannot simply be defeated by
doom in any normal former fashion
especially using the magic that he
currently possesses and so what happens
is that as a result of you know doom
traveling to this realm of Mephisto
there's a massive explosion in the chair
that he's sitting in and what this does
is this seems to indicate that his face
is scarred now this is something that
I'd really like you to keep in mind
because this has been a huge talking
point of Doctor Doom and even in certain
circles it has been a it was it was
basically a case that people were making
on one side of the other for decades
from the time doom first showed up in
Marvel Comics to the Tom ADA got his
origin story going forward the question
was always is dooms face really scarred
or is it just a matter of perception as
he believed his face is scar now this
was not a question we got a definitive
answer to until Jonathan Hickman's
Secret Wars we had never actually seen
doom reveal his face full-on to us as
the reader showing us how deformed it
was we saw indications that it might be
deformed but we didn't know for certain
because of Hickman's run on seeker wars
we know that this resulted in dooms face
being disfigured we know resulted in
dooms face being screwed up the
indication at least from what Ed
Brubaker is telling us is that doom you
know because Secret Wars hadn't been
written by this point that dooms
scarring seem to be psychological it
seemed to be something that he had just
kind of made up in his own mind
so what happens here is that doom begins
to shift his focus away from military
applications of technology to basically
setting himself up as a person that
could begin to take over that could
begin to move down the realm of being a
tried and true villain but with that
being said we're going to bring this
video to an end let me know what you
guys think about this series of the
moment because I think it's actually
pretty cool
I think books of doom is a really really
good series but but even let me know
what you guys think and I will catch you
guys on it peace
you